he sees Maria Bartiromo talks about her
new book her career and the fallout from
the 2008 financial industry meltdown the
Greater Washington Board of Trade hosted
the hour-long event
well welcome to the Board of Trade thank
you very much for joining us
congratulations on the new book honors
and we're thrilled to get you so early
in the process I know that the roadshow
begins
but thanks for spending time with us we
represent a cross-section of the
business community in Greater Washington
and you're probably more familiar with
the business of Greater Washington
lately than you'd like to be because we
live in interesting times that's for
sure so how is the book tour been going
and I want to talk a lot more about
what's in it you've really covered quite
a bit on the keys to success but give us
an idea of what you were thinking when
you decided to spend the time putting
this book together well it's going well
it's been a busy couple of weeks since
the book was launched and I wrote the
book because you know in 2008 when we
were all watching people lose their jobs
and the recession really at its peak and
and the financial system under severe
pressure with iconic firms failing like
Lehman Brothers and Bear Sterns
I started to you know focus on these
people who are coming out of these
high-rise buildings which of course in
and of itself were so emblematic of
success and prosperity and they're
walking out of the buildings and they're
holding their boxes of belongings and I
thought to myself and this is
unbelievable these successful people who
thought that they were at the top of
their game only to find themselves at
the bottom of the heap so how do you
approach your career in life with an
understanding that things are temporary
and there are ways to get through it and
how do you get through it so I felt that
I was in a good position to be able to
reach out to some successful people that
I had been able to interview people like
Jack Welch and Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett and Gary Kasparov and I called
him up and I said talk to me a little
about your own Road how did you do it
how did you achieve this success and and
particularly how do you do it during
really troubled times what happened
during the recession that you endured
and and what happened when you were
worried or your neighbor was worried
about losing their job how do you get
through it
how do you approach a career in in for
the long term endurance and so I think I
came away with
some great insights it was definitely a
departure for me because I typically
write about business and the economy and
markets and that's what I focus on all
the time but in this book I focused on
success and I felt forced to include my
own path my own story because when I was
talking to those people about success I
agreed with so many things and I and I
and I tried to bring my own perspective
to it because I didn't want it to just
be another book of here's Jack Welch's
Laws of Success and here's Bill Gates's
list of success it had to be mine based
on my own interactions and relationships
out there so go through a number of the
chapters as it happens and I mentioned
this on the way in you're our second
speaker from Bay Ridge Brooklyn in the
last month we had Ted Leonsis last month
as a speaker and he grew up in Brooklyn
in fact his dad was a waiter you grew up
in Bay Ridge Brooklyn your dad owned a
restaurant right so tell us a little bit
about you didn't grow up with a silver
silver spoon in your mouth and you
actually address that but probably close
to a spoon in the mouth you worked in
the in the the restaurant the the big
catering hall and all the rest but tell
us a little bit about growing up in Bay
Ridge and and then how that started to
shape your career because you talk a lot
about family in the book it totally
shaped my career and and my story I'm
very proud of because my upbringing
really formed my work ethic it formed
certainly Who I am in terms of the way I
look at things the humility I try to
keep even when you're you know at places
like you know the Board of Trade with
all of you and going to the White House
Correspondents Dinner there's a lot of
stuff you know a lot out there meeting
heads of state and top CEOs you know
recently a friend of mine who is a
genealogist her hobby is to to find
records of people's history family
history and she she found my
grandfather's green card on the Internet
she found the manifest of the ship that
he came to this country on she found a
picture of the ship I was so incredibly
proud it
turns out that I knew this but when you
actually see the manifest and you see
your family members name and the green
card it's astounding and and so she
called me it so anyway my grand father
carmine bartiromo came to America from
Italy first he fought in World War one
for Italy and then in 1919 he decided to
board a ship called the Rex and we all
know you know we're all a product of our
own ancestors but we all know how much
courage that must have taken to leave a
family and friends in a place that you
know so well to get on a boat with the
promise of prosperity and success and
that's exactly what my grandfather did
so weak so he comes to this country in
1919 in Italy he was a bricklayer he was
a construction worker so he comes to
this country and he does what he knows
best he he he builds a restaurant and he
builds a restaurant so he settled in
Brooklyn after landing coming to Ellis
Island he builds a restaurant names it
the Rex Manor after the ship that he
came here on and that was my first job I
was the coach at girl at the Rex Manor
and and that is really Who I am because
my whole life I watched my parents work
so hard
and that work ethic is really it has
been integral to my own success parents
they didn't give you a break you have a
tough day at the office and they're
going Maria it's not a tough day at the
office right my mother would say Maria
please you're not chopping wood you're
not chopping trees
I would come home and exhaust it or you
know working hard I would say oh mama
I'm this and I'm complaining if she said
oh Murray and you're not chopping trees
come on and I said oh you're right I'm
not chopping cheese that's true so it's
but it's great and I would never ever
give that up for anything in the world
I'm so proud and so grateful to have had
the upbringing that I have that hard
work ethic and and I think that that's
probably the the luckiest part of my
story where I was born and the the
shoulders that I stand on my grandfather
and my family so it you have a variety
of chapters here the titles you all have
the books in front of you but seeking a
meaningful path self-knowledge vision
initiative courage will go on for a few
of them you missed that chapter about
the New York in you so talk to us about
your desire to be on camera and how you
ended up being on camera because it was
either gonna be called New York in me or
hutzpah I'm not sure which one but share
with everyone the the approach that you
took to getting your first on-camera
experience you know I ever I mean I
really didn't have the goal of being on
camera when I basically I went to NYU
and I studied economics and when I was a
junior in college my mother said to me
why don't you take journalism I think
you would be good at it and I was taking
economics because I just did well in it
and I just figured well I'll figure it
out at some point you know a student you
don't know what you you want to do but a
econ came easy to me so I just kept
going with it but when my mom said that
I decided to try out journalism I
absolutely loved it
decided to switch my major take more
journalism writing and TV classes ended
up getting an internship at CNN so I was
a little down about it I didn't want to
work for CNN I wanted to work at that
time I wanted to work in 1987 for the
big guys ABC CBS or NBC but I was
accepted to CNN after taking tests and
writing essays and things and so it
ended up being again an amazingly lucky
break because I get to CNN and the first
Gulf War is just about to begin and of
course there was such momentum and CNN
was breaking new ground and I was
to do everything anything that they
needed they just needed a lot of help in
in all areas so rather than going to one
of the union shops of the major networks
where I would just have been given a job
teleprompt just do this one thing I was
able to get my hand in a lot of things
so I ended up writing and producing and
being a field reporter off camera and I
was loving life and then after five
years after I had really climbed the
ladder at CNN and become a senior person
there I had built a great rolodex and I
and I was definitely my my MO was the
wall street beat and so I was I felt
good about it
anyway they off-camera I was a producer
and I would write scripts and go
interview people and then other people
like Jan Hawkins at Terry Keenan kitty
pilgrim would would go on air with my
script and I loved it it was perfect
because I was off camera but anyway they
reassembled the assignment desk and and
Lou Dobbs brought me the great news that
I was getting this promotion but it
wasn't I was taken out of the field and
now I would be in the control room and I
would be the the main producer in those
those people's ear telling them when to
rap bottom line is I was taken out of
really what I felt that I had done well
which is interact with people get the
story be on the ground be outside in the
field and I was very upset about it and
I hate it when they get promoted yeah
more money it was a better title but in
my heart I knew I didn't want that
because I was on such a great track and
so it was a sort of a moment of truth
for me and so I wandered into the ladies
room crying 25 years old and I saw kitty
pilgrim one of the reporters and I said
Oh kitty I'm so upset Lou just gave me
this promotion and I know it's great and
I Myron Kandel is my mentor and I love
it here and I grew up here but I'm not I
don't want to do this job I did this
trouble ready even though I didn't have
the title and she was the first time in
my young career person who actually
suggested I look long-term and she said
to me Maria you have to decide what you
want to do in five years where do you
see yourself in five years and that's
what you need to start working toward
right now and I
five years well okay and then I thought
about all the jobs that I could take at
CNN Business News and I realized that
many of the jobs I had done already in
in one way or another and even though I
didn't have the title so I thought the
only thing left is to try and put myself
on camera so I thought well maybe I
maybe I could do it at least I could
stay in the field and so I reluctantly
took the job and I was done it was the
overnight shift
so I'd done the overnight shift at that
point three times at CNN but this one
was I would end my shift at 8:00 a.m. so
that was another reason that I didn't
want that job after during the overnight
it's for three times so I asked my boss
if I could work extra longer than the
the eight hours and I would go out in
the field and interview people for the
morning economic data that would be
coming out so he said okay if you want
to stay after your 8:00 a.m. finish
after your show ends that's fine you can
do it so it was my plan to get out in
the field with the camera crew so that I
could ask the camera crew to shoot some
shots of me on camera and that's what I
did and I spent the next two months
putting a tape together and the only
place I really wanted to work with CNBC
because that was the only other network
that was really focused on business or
business you're assembling clips that
are never going to be shown right in
your pocket just to put a tape together
and the editors and the cameramen were
great with me they said okay we'll do it
that's fine and so I added a tape I sent
it to CNBC they called me and I was I
was sleeping in my in my house one day
because I was you know going to bed at
9:00 a.m. sleeping all day getting up
again to be at work at 11:00 p.m. so
about two o'clock in the afternoon I
groggily answer the phone and they said
we'd like you to come in for an
interview and I said okay you know we
set it up and then I went on the
interview I knew I had the job we hit it
off immediately and so right then I went
to New York City and I bought two new
dresses even before I had the news
bought the dresses later that day again
in my sleep they called me and they
offered me the job I was at lay I never
went back to sleep that day you've not
slowed down it's just I think it's
testament to what you've done in your
career and you've burst through so many
different of the closed doors certainly
the the floor of the stock exchange yeah
that wasn't exactly the the lady's
favorite area no and I don't think you
were particularly welcomed and you
reflect that in the book you really were
very candid in the book I do want to
talk about a number of the people that
you've interviewed a number of the
people you've dealt with and then you've
got some strong comments in here but
that moved to the stock exchange floor
it put you on radar screens where
everyone was like who's that and I can't
believe she's in the middle of the stock
exchange floor but that wasn't an easy
time the smile on TV not what standing
there it wasn't you know I mean it was
new to all involved I was the first
person to bring a camera down to the
floor of the exchange and turn it on
live and so it was new certainly to me
and it was definitely new to all the
guys on the floor of the exchange and
you know I had some allies but also some
people who gave me pushback luckily dick
Grasso the then CEO of the NYC wanted to
demystify what was going on down there
so he allowed us to do it
Matt Quayle one of the producers at CNBC
had the idea and so we tried it and one
day I learned that Jack Welch the my
then boss's boss was coming down to the
stock exchange and I thought oh this is
such a great break for me I am going to
be the face of CNBC to take Jack to the
post of General Electric to show him he
was the CEO of GE G the parent of CNBC
and so I had met George the guy who was
the specialist bringing buyers together
with sellers on the floor of the
exchange and I thought this is perfect
I'm going to introduce Jack Welch to
George and George will explain to Jack
how the orders come in what happens and
and and and I'll be a hero I'm great and
I was only down there about a month when
this all occurred so I was still getting
my feet wet and so I walked over one day
and it was a quiet day there was only
about 25 or 30 guys in earshot around
the pole
she looked quiet and didn't look like
George was particularly busy I just
wanted to ask him if it was okay that I
brought Jack Welch over the next day and
I said George and this guy who was
double or triple my age who was standing
there in the crowd writing down orders
on his pad screamed at me and he said
run along little girl get away from here
this will not go on your little TV show
and don't ever come back here again is
not your business you won't be here and
I don't want to see you again so I know
that all the 25 or 30 people around me
are waiting for a response maybe waiting
for a fight and I've got the knots in my
stomach going and I just tried to get
some dignity and I said don't speak to
me that way
and I ran along but I came back and I
kept coming back and but it was it was
difficult because this one guy was so
uncomfortable with I don't know if it
was a female or a reporter I don't know
what he was but he hated me
literally for five maybe seven years he
gave me such a hard time and then I
later learned that he was on the board
of the New York Stock Exchange so I said
great this is a real thorn in my side
but you know I used to I used to go
around the building to go to where I
needed to go because I didn't want to
pass him because he would say things
like save your money you know really
really the verge you're not going to
imagine anything you better save your
money so after then in the.com years the
market started falling and people were
really upset and getting getting angry
and and at that point I had been there a
good seven or eight years and he's still
giving me a hard time and I finally
toughened up so once I walked by him and
he said save you money and I said no no
no no you save your money and I kept
walking and I just thought victory
you write that story and you tell that
story just as you wrote it and the end
the passion comes through on it now I
won't tell you how it ends it's pretty
good ending though not the book that's
story that's just part of it but
everybody has a copy of the book so you
can you can flip through the page later
on I do want to talk though about
banking goodwill for the long haul and
then that's your your phrase Bank
goodwill for the long term on page 110
one of the secrets of my success is that
I'm always finding ways to bank goodwill
for the future constantly aware of
building relationships journalism is all
about that sure I want the interview
today the pressure is on but I forced
myself to be patient you talked to us a
little bit about this is in the chapter
on initiative and you really do provide
a variety of different specific examples
not just yours but a lot of prominent
people in the business setting in the
political setting and you use these
types of snippets to really bring life
to the different chapters well you know
I mean I think banking goodwill is
important I think people need to know
who you are and the kind of person you
are and the way you operate in order to
trust you and you know the media is is a
funny thing because half the people are
afraid of the media because they don't
want to be questioned you're going
camera and the other half just thinks
look they get it wrong all the time
so I was very aware of this having been
a producer and I am very careful to
ensure that when I am interviewing
someone I speak to the P the person if I
can beforehand to ensure that I
understand the story and I understand
his or her agenda everybody has an
agenda and I recognize that I have an
agenda to my agenda is to make sure that
I get investors access to the people who
they want access to and get the
information out there in an accurate
calm way and and hopefully in a timely
way they have an agenda too they're not
speaking to me because they love me
they're speaking to me because they want
to get a message out and I think once
you understand the other person's agenda
it's okay you know what they're trying
to do and you know what you're trying to
do but then you know you
ask the questions that you need to ask
the questions that viewers want to
answer to investors want to answer it
not in a gotcha kind of way just in a
way but this is certainly the way I do
it and in a way that says look here are
the issues what are you doing about it
and so I do try to ensure that the
people that I'm interviewing and I'm
having on the show understand that I've
done the work and I have put the time in
to understand the story and I've spoken
with people who like the company don't
like the company investor shorting the
stock whatever it is to educate myself
as much as possible but I give some
examples in the book about banking
goodwill for the future because I know
that you know getting the get during a
tough time getting the interview that
everyone wants to hear when that person
really doesn't want to speak is a coup
and so if I could make sure that the
public and that person understands that
I am going to be fair but at the same
time you're going to give you an
opportunity to lay your case out then I
think I've done my job
oh you do the job very well and I want
to hit on two pieces here in the chapter
on courage but then jump to one on
humility you you're very candid about
not the fears really but let's talk
about Yankee Stadium so summary has
invited to throw out the opening pitch
at Yankee Stadium
not exactly a Little League field but
not that you'd pass that up and for
anybody that's a that's a long stretch
that's that's quite a throw well that's
sixty feet so so lady of numbers you say
yes and then and then well talk to us a
little bit about Dan's words your friend
Dan because the butterflies really got
going well when they asked me to throw
the first pitch a Yankee Stadium
obviously I was elated I was so I was
just oh wow you know and after getting
over that I realized I am NOT a pitcher
I'm not a baseball player I have no idea
what I'm doing and I certainly don't
want to get booed out of my hometown
with 60,000 fans sitting there in Yankee
Stadium so I said to myself okay I am
going to do this and I'm going to
practice so I spent the next four months
pitching and practicing and learning
baseball with my friend Dan and he was
he could not have been greater he was
took the time every weekend and at night
we would go to the park and we would
throw the ball around and after a while
I felt what I got it I felt wow you know
I could actually pitch this is going to
be good so the day of the game Dan comes
to my house with my husband and the
three of us get in the car we go to
Yankee Stadium and I actually had my
producer with me because I actually had
to have my own camera crew role on it I
was so amazed that I was actually doing
this so I turned to my producer Lulu and
I say lo how you doing she said I'm
having a freakout I said me - I can't
believe we're here so we're in the
dugout and I'm just throwing the ball
with with one of the players and it
wasn't going well at all even though I
had practiced for four months and so
McGwire turns to me and he says oh
you're gonna bounce it and I said no no
and he said you definitely in it bounced
I'm watching you right now you know you
don't had a pitch and I said okay I'm
gonna do this and so I turned to Dan and
I say Dan what am I doing here I said
I'm not a pitcher I can't even believe I
put myself in this position why would I
do such a thing he looked me right in
the eye and he said to me Maria remember
one thing you are exactly where you're
supposed to be and I said you're right
I am I am exactly where I'm supposed to
be he said go out there and know it I
said you're right I've got out there
the first thing I did to get out so that
they announced my name in the last
speaker and my family's in the stands
60,000 fans I run out to the dugout
first thing I do is go yeah route you
know and Matt gets myself what an ego
you idiot
now you're really gonna bounce it but
then I took a breath and I said okay
Maria you are exactly we were supposed
to be I got the confidence I threw the
ball right in the pitchers mitt didn't
even move a muscle I over the plate I
was so happy about it but that was so
powerful what Dan said to me and even
till this day I'm interviewing heads of
state or if I get butterflies and in any
situation I think to myself Maria you
are exactly where you're supposed to be
and it just reminds me that I've done
the work I should have the confidence
there's nothing to be afraid of because
I know I've prepared and when you are
prepared and when you know what you've
done
lose the butterflies because you're
exactly where you're supposed to be and
so that line was so powerful for me and
I just like thanks Dan so much because a
great story and it's it's interesting in
the chapter on humility where you talk
about relax you're human it would
surprise many in the room and it
certainly surprised me that as much face
time as you have on TV you weren't
comfortable standing up at a podium
giving a speech and and this was the the
parts this nobody likes to fail but
everyone does at some point in fact it's
a fact of life I struggled with this
idea early years on being on camera the
business was competitive and you go
through that but then it says since I
was young and lacked full confidence and
myself the idea of not being good at
something was terrifying I was often
asked to speak in front of groups and it
wasn't something that came naturally it
didn't matter that I appeared on
television in front of millions of
viewers standing in it standing at a
podium before a live audience was
different for a long time I was really
terrible at public speaking and then one
of your bosses Pamela Thomas Graham
confronted me about my performance
she was blunt Maria in your position
people expect that you can stand at a
microphone and deliver but you get up
there and you look like a deer in the
headlights
so clearly scared you let your audience
down you have to fix this yeah well now
I'm just sort of let me interject I'm
not sure anybody that has that fear
would have written it down in the book
to share with the world but it speaks to
what you've done in this book you really
did present yourself with a with a human
face it's the distance on TV is
something but when you go through this
book to address it those are the things
you shared in addition to as we'll get
to them a number of the interviews in
the comments you have about the people
you've talked to not gossip really just
good observations but talk to me just a
little bit about when you when you hired
this coach how you change the approach
because I think it's very telling about
your approach to presentations just like
this one it's true and and that's what I
meant when I said it was a departure for
me because this is not something that
I've ever done before written about my
own experience and and success from from
other people's standpoint but it's true
I was nervous speaking in front of
people and you know it's it's funny
because people get surprised about that
because I am on camera so much and and
it's always live but when you're in
front of a group like this or you know
even in larger groups it's scary you
look at people and you think what do
they like me do they not like a million
things going in going through your head
about about live audiences so I would
always clam up as soon as I got to that
podium I was a nervous wreck and so
Pamela set me straight and said look
more you need to fix this you why don't
you get a coach go go meet with someone
so I met with this lovely woman and the
first thing she said to me was what are
you trying to say and I said well and I
looked at my script and she's no no no
put the script away what are you trying
to say and I said well I'm just trying
to say and and I said it and she's do
but that's all you have to do because
you know people invited you to speak all
they want to do is hear what you have to
say and they want to hear it from your
heart nobody wants you a cardboard
cutout reading the same script over and
over again that you just change a couple
of line to the top of it so that it's
relevant for whatever group and so it
was so thought-provoking for me that
today somebody years later I never write
scripts when I go speak to groups what I
do is I write a
couple of themes maybe I'll talk about
financial reform maybe I'll talk about
you know the economy the glue you know
the global story I just write three or
four notes down and that's it and then I
get to the podium and I say I did not
write a script today because I wanted to
talk to you from my heart and here's how
I see things and it's amazing because
right off the bat you're connecting with
people because they know you're not
reading something that you've read a
hundred times and it's just a canned
script but you're actually talking from
your heart and it really changed
everything for me
and I put it in the book because I think
it's so important when achieving success
and when trying to achieve success to be
authentic people do not want to look at
someone who is all you know bottled up
they would like to know who you really
are what you're thinking about and so
authenticity I think is so critical in
terms of getting ahead and so it
certainly helped me a lot there's a very
nice job and it really comes through the
book and then you go into the chapter on
integrity and you didn't pull any
punches there and we'll get into a few
of the other areas but this was a
surprising comment from you there's one
positive outcome of the crisis in the
financial sector is that we've opened up
a national conversation about what it
means to have integrity in business that
conversation has taken hold in the
schools where the future leaders of
business and industry are trained and in
some cases lured to lucrative jobs now
their motivations are changing just a
quarter mile from the US Capitol some of
the issues earlier this week on the
hearings and more it has been sobering
for the students coming out of school
for those choosing to go into school for
a lot of people and we can talk a little
bit about executive pay as well but talk
to us a little bit about your thoughts
on integrity and the people that you've
dealt with that have it and don't well
first off I mean we all know what
integrity feels like and what it looks
like it's just doing the right thing and
we all know when we're faced with the
situation what is the right thing and I
think that at the end of the day people
want to be around integrity they want to
be near you they want to follow you they
trust you and it inspires confidence I
mean you can have all
in the world and you know all the
supposed success in the world and not
have integrity and I do not think that's
success I think you cannot be successful
without integrity and I think that it
inspires group said it enables people to
take groups to places they did not know
they could they could go and I think
that integrity is critical and I think
over the last couple of years we were
operating a financial system that was
operating with a lack of integrity
because obviously when you have forty to
one leverage and you've got five dollars
in the bank but you borrow 200 that's
not integrity and so I think when you
look at certain situations whether it's
the lack of integrity like that or where
you have integrity and you see people
making the right decisions for the good
of the people and constituents I think
that it ends up a very different
scenario than what we've seen you know I
think what has happened over the last
ten years is we were so Lord by
compensation and you know students I
spent some time at Stanford recently and
had a chance to talk to some students
about what they're doing in NYU and I've
been I've been talking with a number of
university heads and speaking to
students and I love the energy of the
university but what happened over the
last 10 years is we had such an enormous
part of the economy being financial
services because of this allure of
compensation and people coming out of
schools talented students rather than
going into careers that truly
represented the underpinnings of our
economy whether it's healthcare or
biotech or infrastructure energy they
chose financial services because
financial services offer them a large
compensation so not only was financial
services sucking up a large part of the
sp500 but it was also taking up a lot of
our talented students who were instead
of going to industries that they loved
and industries that would have been
really a backbone for the economy they
went toward financial services and I
think now we're seeing a change I think
people are reassessing what they would
like to do because the jobs are not
there for starters you didn't mince the
words on the executive compensation but
it was also balanced and I want to be I
want to be clear about that so you you
go back to the to the restaurants that
as a kid growing up around my father's
restaurant I received a pretty basic
understanding of earnings and Worth
my dad cooked his heart out to serve the
best food now was they you start
thinking about being raised with a
fundamental of understanding of what we
earn is connected to how we perform a
viewer wrote in to you and said in real
life you don't get a bonus for running
your firm into the ground now executive
compensation is all in the headlines and
certainly on CNBC with your show talk to
us a little bit about the the balance of
the two the people who've worked hard to
achieve it but now are getting ripped
apart
all over the place and then those that
didn't deserve it well of course this is
why we have such anger from the people
because we are looking at a portion of
our great country losing their jobs and
losing their homes and watching the
value of their investments move lower
while you've got you know some so-called
fat cats on Wall Street and in business
earning a lot of money and unfortunately
taking the firm's into the ground and so
I am a big proponent of paper for
performance and I think that you know
part of me feels that it's really not
the government's role to set
compensation levels I do feel that
firmly I think that we have a structure
in place boards management teams that
that should be doing this but they also
should be taking accountability
responsibility for it at the same time I
think that we should have performance as
the dictator of how much someone makes
and so you know I would like to see
boards and management teams take up this
responsibility more aggressively because
I think it's important andrew Cuomo said
to me people do not go into the water
again until they know the shark is dead
and I think that there's some truth to
that because I think people want to feel
like whoever's fault it is is paying the
price and is being held accountable and
that's not that doesn't mean walking
away from a firm that has dropped to the
lows with the two hundred million dollar
severance package the numbers are
mind-boggling so I understand the anger
out there it's unfortunate that we are
looking at something of a class warfare
in in some corners but I don't think the
anger is misplaced in the chapter still
on integrity because I'd like to focus a
little bit in this area there were a
variety of different telling stories so
here's the subtitle of one of the pieces
for the chapter tell the truth was kind
of is bothersome that you have to put
that in a book for people in the
business community or elsewhere that
you'd have to remind them but you talked
about being taken aback when Alan
Greenspan admitted something to you can
you talk to us a little bit about that
yeah I mean Alan Greenspan who I'm a big
fan of said to me look I opt for ski I
you know oftentimes I'm asked questions
about where interest rates are going and
where the economy is going and instead
of answering the question I will talk a
lot on a long time in very complicated
sentences so that by the end of all of
those complicated sentences the the
questionnaire has no idea if I answer
the question or not and I actually
didn't say anything at all and now for
Alan Greenspan let's put him at a
different level than than others because
I understand
well it's I put it in there because you
know it was funny to me and I was taking
it back to learn that he actually did
have a plan it was all by design to go
and talk because he's done it to me a
hundred times and then I say okay got it
and it's like what did he just answer my
question or not you know but the truth
is is what he says and he's different at
that you know I mean he was arguably the
most important financial figure in the
world and so his his words really moved
markets and so when you are talking
about someone who's actually moving
markets to that extent I think you
really do have to be very sensitive
about answering the questions directly
so I I do do believe Alan Greenspan has
great integrity but he certainly did
confuse the question or many a times and
he admits it I've got a few other
personalities to go through so let's
let's talk about Greenspan Spitzer
Madoff and the Russian President and
Jack Walsh a little bit now Madoff
here's the here's the title of the
subchapter sleep at night how do you
sleep in how do you sleep it yeah we
slept at night I mean this was just a
fraud that was going on for so long I
guess he just started to believe his own
lies but it's extraordinary I didn't put
it all with him to you know I just quote
they ignored the tiny voices of doubt
that told him there was no pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow and you were
talking about the investors the people
who felt like I had special access
because Bernie was going to take care of
me well that was one of Bernard Madoff
brilliance 'as you know he made it just
it was a little hard to get into his
so-called club that you actually thought
getting into the club and and allowing
him to take your money to invest it for
you was a really fortunate thing and you
were one of the few lucky ones out there
and so and then even if you questioned
how he was actually investing because
there was some speculation that he was
actually you know running ahead of other
clients and and and having a having an
edge because it was very shady because
he actually knew where the flow was and
knew what's what stock was going to go
up so he would be first in line and used
his clients money so there was a feeling
about you know well how is he actually
doing this maybe this is a
this is sort of a gray area but I want
in anyway so the investors they was also
slide they knew it wasn't some of them
knew that it wasn't all on the line and
you know on the level but they wanted to
be in there anyway because they wanted
to be part of his club that he that he
said was you know so exclusive and so it
was greed and you know you saying you
you don't think the ripple effect of
Madoff is finished no I don't I mean I
think that there will be more heads to
roll and the investigations continue and
I think as we peel back the onion on
trying to figure out how this individual
masterminded this fraud I think we'll
learn a lot more about how he did it and
who else was involved yeah I don't think
we're done with that yet then there's
the don't be a white knight with dirty
hands Eliot Spitzer these are well you
know when Eliot Spitzer what I liked
about it is that all of the strong
comments aren't yours you're just
quoting other people they didn't mince
their words ken Langone is one of those
people in there and he definitely didn't
mince words when it came to Eliot
Spitzer look I think Eliot Spitzer did a
great service when he was trying to
uncover Wall Street fraud and I think
part of the reason that people were so
afraid of him and and you know walked on
eggshells around him is because of that
that he was you know notorious and sort
of a you know a fraud fighter and he was
going to get the bad guys on Wall Street
unfortunately in some cases people felt
that he was the judge the jury and the
executor and you know particularly as it
relates to I don't know let's say dick
Grasso or let's say Hank Greenberg I
think he went on one of the Sunday
morning shows and he said Hank Greenberg
committed fraud and you know I mean you
could you could like the guy or hate the
guy and I don't want to be a defender
for you know Wall Street Titans but you
don't go on a Sunday morning TV show and
and and broadcast that somebody
committed fraud unless you actually have
the evidence and of course the evidence
never showed up but of course the
public's mind was made up by that time
and then you know Eliot Spitzer's career
blew up with his with his own
indiscretions and I think that you know
when
when very few people came to his defense
during that time I wondered if it was
because people felt that he was the
judge the jury and the executor in in
some cases and maybe that actually hurt
him to the extent that you know it was
almost bully tactics well it's the
corollary to the chapter that you have
on bank the goodwill he didn't have any
that's right here is the quote from Ken
we all have our own private hell's I
hope his is hotter than anybody else's
so then you're in in Russia yeah now
this is under the chapter of
adaptability and and I when I was going
through the table of contents I wondered
where you're going to go with
adaptability is it is that the personal
adaptability is it business adaptability
you didn't start off small you started
off with Russia evil empire is it's
referred to from long not so long ago
but long ago and and there you are
meeting or planning to meet with the
president to us a little bit about the
adaptability mindset what you were
thinking and why that's important to you
and the enduring keys to success I think
adaptability is critical particularly at
this moment in time as it relates to
Russia I was meeting President Medvedev
and you know as I was approaching the
interview I was thinking about the
history of Russia and the evil empire
and the Russia the you know Russians
versus the United States and you know I
thought wow you know amazing that here
we are looking at an economy that is
trying to integrate itself into the
world system and yet people question
whether or not there is the rule of law
here and you know when I interviewed the
president he was talking about how the
country was trying to adapt to different
energy sources and they didn't want to
be so reliant on oil which of course is
so rich in their country but oil had
plummeted to $32 a barrel down from $147
a barrel
really putting a scare into officials in
Russia so they were planning to create
new revenue sources and trying to
rely on technology and now they're
actually creating a whole city next to
Moscow that they want to they wanted to
be like Silicon Valley and they are
trying to really encourage innovations
but what the point I was trying to make
was that we all need to adapt to what's
happening we all need to look at the
realistic situations around us and
particularly right now in this economy
everything's changing the immediate
business obviously has changed
dramatically with the digital revolution
financial services has already changed
quite dramatically and will continue to
change with financial regulatory reform
coming down the pike Healthcare of
course have changed so I think it's very
important to always look within us
always look at your own skill sets and
assess what do I do well where are my
skill sets and where are the holes in my
skill sets because we will need to adapt
somebody in the book is something
someone I interviewed for the book said
to me Maria I am a steel I worked on a
steel mill for thirty years I have a
family of five and my mill was just
closed down and now I'm out of a job so
what do I know about making solar panels
and frankly he's absolutely right he
doesn't know anything about making solar
panels but that's the point we need to
ensure that we are best positioned for
how this economy is changing because
going forward the changes are not
waiting for us and it may be new
training that you need it might be a
mentor it might be you know aside one
class or two classes to take to ensure
that you have the goods to empower
yourself with with the right skill set
to actually survive and thrive in the
changes in the economy because the
changes aren't waiting and I think that
adaptability is so critical to the
environment that we are in right now and
that's why I wanted to make sure that I
highlighted that well and you go after
the the focus on the strengths you say
that build your own credentials make a
case for yourself that you live by this
principle and you talk about your
husband John oh is it John Oh John oh
yeah John oh I've met him so go with
John oh thank you very much but about
his approach about his humility about
his with his dad and
and the the challenges in the industry
for his dad and so he he does take care
of a lot of other people you take care
of a lot of other people but it's the
focusing on the strength build your own
credentials make a case for yourself
that's a big part of adaptability yes it
really is I mean I think that you have
to be comfortable with who you are which
is why the first law of enduring success
in my book is self-knowledge you really
need to know who you are know what your
skill set is and and know that you have
a comfort feeling that you actually do
operate with integrity and I mentioned
my husband because I do believe that he
does very much he always does the right
thing and you know it was amazing to me
because we we grew up very differently
you know he his family he grew up
wealthy and his family you know really
had all the luxuries in life you know I
I love my upbringing as I said earlier
but it was very different growing up in
Brooklyn than my husband but he's so
down to earth and and humble and I
admire that about him because he could
have been very very different in st.
Petersburg again at the International
Economic Forum that whole timeframe and
the topic of conversation comes up where
you chaired the panel about the
government's ownership role in business
this wasn't because you were in Russia
this was made up of people from all over
the world the consensus from the panel
in the audience was that government
would have a significant stake in
business for the foreseeable future and
it wasn't exactly a get over it moment
but it was on the adaptability this is
the new reality yes Jerris your share
with us your thoughts about the role of
government in business well I think that
it is the new normal right now and I
think that government is going to have
much more oversight of certainly a
number of industries in particular
financial services and I think that you
know it's not a question of you know
will this change it's happening and this
is the reality and I think that it's
it's very important to look at a
situation and recognize the reality and
and deal with it and not try to hem and
haw how can I change it how can I get
around it you know maybe it won't happen
you know I think that after what we've
been through in terms of the financial
upset the financial system coming so
close to collapse and and the recession
and so much unemployment I think people
are looking at where we are and
to figure out how it plays out for them
and I do believe that we will see much
more oversight it could be that we go
too much in one direction perhaps we did
that with sarbanes-oxley but like I said
earlier people need to have a feeling
that there's accountability and that
there's change in order to trust the
system and trust and confidence in the
system is the most important thing in
this section on adaptability under
darwinian say you say it occurs to me
though that we can get suckered by the
knew just as easily as we can get
trapped by the old talk to us a little
bit about your your thoughts on that
because of the new media because of the
sort of the latest new shiny object you
can get you can get persuaded pretty
quickly
yeah and it's and it's like we have been
persuaded pretty quickly over the booms
and the bus you know I remember when we
were in the dot-com era we used to have
a segment on CNBC we would call it
annoying little comparisons where my
colleague David Faber would get up on
on-camera and he would say okay here's
my annoying little comparison for the
day let's look at the market value of
Joe schmo's pizza place and compared to
Ford Motor and of course Joe schmo's
pizza place had no revenue and no
earnings and Ford was a global company
with real profitability and yet the
smaller company had a larger market
value so we were had we were in this
mentality of anything with the dot-com
was going to was going to be the future
and I think that you know what I tried
to say was let's get back to basics
because if it looks too good to be true
it probably is
and we did the same thing with oil where
you know oil was rallying and rallying
all the way to 147 dollars a barrel and
when it was at 147 Goldman came out with
a report and said it's going to 200 and
of course next stop was 32 and so I
think that it's very important to look
for that integrity in any market and
look for that fundamental you know
strength and and and and the fundamental
backdrop of a story if it's too good to
be true it probably is and I think we
all have to take individual
responsibility for the decisions that we
make when it comes to investing when it
comes to looking at something
realistically when you go through on the
book you you there probably are a
hundred different people that you've
covered in here in different stories
from them but Jack Welch
this was the quote boy sounds like Jack
and you talk to about you talked to him
about Mentors and you asked him about
finding a mentor he said looking for a
mentor is the dumbest idea in the world
noticing my shock he smiled and added
what you want he's a hundred Mentors can
you talk to us a little bit about your
approach on mentors and then I'd like to
open it up for a few minutes with
questions with the audience before we we
get you to your next appointment okay
yeah I think that it was a great point
and I and I had never looked at it that
way because I always thought you know I
who is my mentor and I would think of
one or two people but he's saying you
don't want to you know attach your star
to one person who comes with baggage and
necessarily do everything the way that
one person did it I think you want to
take you know the best qualities of a
lot of people that you meet and
recognize that you don't want to be
someone else you want to be yourself but
it's okay to look around you and try and
gain the best things from from some of
the mentors around your mentor already
has a history in the company he has
enemies I've even spent maybe he's been
a jerk at times why would you want to
take on that baggage I mean you can
check it what's fun about this book is
that you share so much from everybody
and how you've distilled it and made it
very approachable and bite-size pieces
that that resonate with good stories it
really sticks with you
thanks for sharing well one one story
that I loved was Garry Kasparov the
chess champion who said to me I said to
him Gary what are the lessons you learn
sitting at that chess table and beating
all of these chess champions around the
world and he said well one thing that I
always do is I scrutinize my victories
and and all of us when we have a failure
we always scrutinize the failure we say
oh I should have done this differently I
should have done that differently and
gosh of course I should have done that
but we never scrutinized the victories
we just win it and we walk and Gary said
what I do is I look at the board and I
say ha fooled them again how could I
have done that better next time which I
thought was a great insight thank you
for sharing that let's open it up for a
couple of questions from the audience
and if you'd wait on the microphone is
that right Kyle Thanks
with a very loud microphone
any comments on burning embers uh
burning embers you know I wear Texas
your memory doesn't it yeah it does you
know I think Bernie Evers had such
hubris those parties and the riches and
everyone's faces you know it it reminds
you of the humility story and how you
know I firmly believe that you really
have to always recognize that sure
you're smart and yes you probably have
great talent to have achieved the
success that you have but you also had a
lot of luck along the way and I think
it's so important for people to
recognize and admit you know the luck
that they've had in terms of in terms of
getting there and not believe your own
press releases and and keep the humility
now there was obviously you know fraud
in in that situation
III think I interviewed Bernard Ebbers
once and it was during you know it's
after the charges so you know I didn't I
didn't really know him very well but he
you know got caught up in thinking that
obviously you know his story and and and
he was was better and bigger than
everybody else and and pushed the
envelope and I think at the end of the
day everything comes out in the wash and
you know so now I don't really have I
don't really know him so well so were
you surprised by the audacity of the
gentleman from Goldman sort of saying to
Congress no we didn't do this or is that
is that part of the game under way you
know the Goldman Sachs story is is
really fascinating one and and and could
end up being you know a great case study
for what's going on right now I don't
know I think those those four guys that
were first testifying last week what
struck me was when Senator Collins said
do you feel you have a responsibility to
do the best thing for your clients and
they and they could not say it and they
you know they could not say
yes I feel a duty to to do the right
thing for my clients I think it was
probably because they were so scared
about saying the wrong thing because
they had been you know lawyered up and
talking to lawyers for so long that they
were afraid of any person or anything
that they would say and and it's true
anything that they say is can be used
against them but to miss such an obvious
thing of course you have a duty to your
clients was extraordinary to the memo
about don't send out emails that say
you're fabulous in widows and orphans
that didn't seize the emails look I
think you know what we will see about
how this plays out I think fraud charges
are oftentimes hard to prove you know I
think what you saw last week in Goldman
Sachs was the fact that it was 11 hours
showed that you know they kept going
trying to you know get to as many things
as they can I don't think there were any
body blows I don't think there were any
major body blows for Goldman Sachs
during that hearing good at the same
time I don't think that they convinced
America that that they they are on the
level here so I think that there's big
challenges ahead it's gonna be a long
and protracted battle Thanks so another
question
jobs Oh
should a shareholder be concerned about
this healthy seems to be he's the CTO
he's chief technology officer visionary
for the whole company I guess
full disclosure doesn't mean you have to
talk about in their case yeah I was a
little unnerved when when the company
was not more forthcoming about how sick
Steve Jobs was and I mean I don't know
where that stands today but before he
went for the transplant of operation I
actually do think that when you're
talking about someone as integral to the
company's success and its growth as
Steve Jobs has been I do think that the
company has a duty to be more
forthcoming actually I was disappointed
in that and I think they handled it
poorly I agree with you
well I would have to say this moment the
best because it's not a good story but
the most educational and the most
compelling story was the story of the
housing bust and the story of Lehman
Brothers declaring bankruptcy Merrill
Lynch being sold I mean you know if you
think about 2008 if only Lehman Brothers
went bankrupt that would have been an
extraordinary story and yet you had
firms that came close to collapsing or
out-and-out collapsing including Lehman
Brothers Bear Stearns Northern Rock
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac you know
Washington Mutual
Citigroup I mean it was an extraordinary
year and I think that that was an
unbelievable story to cover because it
truly was the story of our country
coming close to collapse in the
financial system and you know I don't
say that lightly because I'm usually not
a dramatist and you know I try very hard
to keep things in check and that weekend
I was at home and well first the first
weekend when I learned that Bear Stearns
was gonna sell for $2 a share I was
astounded and then when when Lehman was
declaring bankruptcy and Merrill was
sold to Bank of America and then AIG a
couple of days later the government
acquiring 80% of AIG I think that was
such an unbelievably extraordinary story
because for the first time you realized
that we are living in such a vulnerable
system and you you recognized that
too-big-to-fail is seriously dangerous
and and I don't know that it's too big
to fail as much as it's too connected to
fail because I don't want to misspeak I
don't necessarily think that all big
companies are bad because in often time
you know in often cases they actually a
large company can offset weaknesses and
in some parts of the business when you
have different
business lines but when you're too
connected to fail I think we all learned
a great lesson about how things work and
about actually how vulnerable things
were so that was by far I mean I also of
course was on Wall Street during
September 11th and that was an
extraordinary moment for our country and
again one of those moments where we all
assessed what was important and I talked
about that a little in the book as well
when I talk about purpose but certainly
you know look I feel so fortunate to
have been able to cover so many really
irritating events from my seat on Wall
Street and having and being broadcast
from the New York Stock Exchange
beginning with the individual investor
revolution when you know the beginning
when investors felt empowered to
actually make their own investment
decisions about saving and investing for
the long term and then globalization how
you know one thing said in one corner of
the world ripples around the world and
then the dot-com boom and and the
technology boom and how technology is
changing so many of our industries
really an extraordinary story there and
then of course the housing boom and and
and bust but you know technology is also
a huge and interesting story for me I
mean in health care alone I went to the
Cleveland Clinic recently and I was so
impressed with what they're doing with
technology at one corner of the clinic
it's a hundred and fifty acres long one
corner of the clinic they've got very
sophisticated technology a
technologically advanced radiology
machine so I went into an operating room
I was standing in it was a large room I
wasn't anywhere near the table and they
were operating on this woman's heart and
and and it's this machine with several
arms you know it on in her body and then
there's all these screens so that they
see everything that's going on in every
corner of the woman's body and then we
go to another place in the clinic and
they've got robots programmed walking
around and the robots it's it's
extraordinary what they're doing at the
Cleveland Clinic clinic they are robots
that look like laundry baskets large
laundry baskets and then on the bottom
of it it's on wheels with two lights
that look like eyes
and they traveled to one corner of the
clinic and they pick up medical
equipment from the docs that put it in
the basket and then they're programmed
to bring it to different places in this
150 acres and it was extraordinary to me
and then another technology change that
I just heard about which is what ge is
doing they looked at where the need was
for breast cancer exams and they
realized that in India there was a great
need for mobile ultrasound machines so
now GE is is creating something that it
looks like a cell phone it's it's small
it's called the V chip and it is a
mobile ultrasound machine where women
are being tested for breast cancer in
India with this with this mobile device
I just think that technology is changing
everything we do in so many industries
and that also is extraordinary but but
certainly by far the most interesting
story and I don't call it best I call it
most interesting was the housing bust
unfortunately it came with job losses
and and valuations plummeting but it was
really fascinating to watch and to cover
and to hear from people and
unfortunately now we're looking at
Greece and Spain and Portugal and
another world crisis or a continuation
of world crisis we'll continue to watch
you in the show it's a the humility
chapter that says be grateful thank you
very much for spending the time with us
really appreciate it
Maria Bartiromo
is the anchor of CNBC's closing bell
with Maria Bartiromo
and host and managing editor of the
nationally syndicated Wall Street
Journal report with Maria Bartiromo for
more information visit Bartiromo dot-com
every weekend c-span - spoke TV features
48 hour